one non-profit is hoping to reduce the
number of deadly crashes involving teams
mary jane bellissa shares how drivers
edge is teaching young drivers how to be
safe on our roads all with the goal of
saving lives
according to the national traffic
highway administration car crashes are
the number one killer of american teens
driver's edge hopes to change that
through their instructional and
educational program driver's edge
founder and ceo jeff payne says parents
and their young drivers will learn skid
control evasive lane changes and
defensive driving skills to better
prepare themselves out on the road
there's more young people killed in car
crashes than by violent crimes and by
drug use combined it's an epidemic and
it doesn't need to be that way this is
daryn hansen and his daughter audrey's
second time attending driver's edge he
says it's all about practice
for an experience of learning and just
to help make her a better driver and so
this i'm hoping will give me the
confidence to know what i need to do in
those situations abigail deacon wants to
improve on her reaction time as she
learns how to stop a car from
hydroplaning better timing for me yeah
which i already suck at timing of my
turns and all that so
i should really fix that work on that
but it wasn't too scary
we also live in las vegas and this will
probably not very likely happen on the
road too often michaela rodriguez says
this course is teaching her how to stay
calm in unexpected scenarios i thought
it'll help me be a little less nervous
than i usually am
because i'm really
a nervous person most the time and we
hope everyone walks away with a greater
awareness and a greater respect for
driving and just as importantly having
that what if mentality out there on the
roads reporting from checkered flag lane
and speedway boulevard mary jean
vallieza live local now